[Musica]
Buonasera a
tutti qui mi vedete nelle mie due vesti
per cui ringrazio di essere stato
invitato dovete sapere che 20 anni fa a
Treviso ho tenuto il mio primo concerto
come direttore d'orchestra e da poco più
di 20 anni che faccio il medico di cui
13 di pronto
soccorso il tema dell'eredità mi fa
venire in mente una frase importante di
uno de dei maestri più importanti che ho
avuto la fortuna di incontrare che si
chiama Kurt masur è un famoso direttore
d'orchestra scomparso nel
2015 teneva questi corsi e raccontava a
noi suoi
allievi tante cose tra cui questa frase
Se voi avete un talento perché ve l'ha
dato Dio se credete in Dio o i vostri
genitori se non credete in Dio non
potete tenerlo per voi ma dovete
metterlo al servizio degli altri della
comunità io non vengo da una famiglia di
musicisti in senso stretto mio padre era
un insegnante era un amatore autodidatta
suonava un po' la chitarra un po' il
pianoforte aveva un gruppo da ragazzo i
Summer Boys nel periodo dei Beatles e
dei Rolling Stones suo padre suonava la
chitarra suo fratello e suo nipote lo
stesso e un suo cugino insegnò anche in
conservatorio mia madre era pure un
insegnante e suo padre aveva suonato il
violino
da da ragazzo ma la nonna diceva che io
ero troppo vivace questo bambino
bisognava mettergli qualcosa in mano e
quindi ho iniziato a studiare il
pianoforte mi sono diplomato mi sono
diplomato in direzione d'orchestra ho
studiato composizione e a questo ho
abbinato un'attività di approfondimento
di dibattito culturale di scrittura e
sono entrato a contatto con L'Eredità
della storia dove ho visto che la vita
non è stata mai vista a una
dimensione soprattutto nel dopoguerra
l'era tecnocratica ci ha spinti a
pensare le persone a una sola dimensione
Nell'era delle ipers
specializzazione questo signore lo
conoscete tutti Leonardo da Vinci è
stato un genio pittore ma anche
scienziato architetto ingegnere pensate
che fu mandato da Lor magnifico da
ragazzo alla corte di Ludovico il Moro a
Milano in qualità di musico perché tra
le varie abilità di Leonardo c'era
quella di costruire strumenti musicali
ma la figura di Leonardo ci dice una
cosa
fondamentale che la dimensione dell'arte
e la dimensione della Scienza convivono
dentro di noi e non sono
separabili successivamente questo
signore ha fatto tante cose si chiama
Theodor Amadeus Hoffman Amadeus in onore
di Mozart
Hoffman è stato uno dei più importanti
scrittori del Romanticismo ha scritto
molte favole e racconti fantastici ma è
stato anche un importante critico
musicale e uno dei più importanti
critici musicali di Beethoven Però
voleva fare anche il pittore ma rinunciò
a questa attività in realtà Hoffman era
anche un compositore scrisse 11 opere un
overtour una sinfonia e tanta musica da
camera Sapete qual era la sua attività
principale era laureato in legge e
lavorava come giurista e magistrato
presso l'amministrazione
prussiana se veniamo in Italia la figura
di Pietro lichtental è forse più nota
gli addetti ai lavori perché lichtental
è stato uno dei primi biografi di Mozart
amico di suo figlio e come attività
principale aveva quella di censore pr a
Milano per il regno Lombardo Veneto
quindi unattività amministrativa ma la
sua occupazione di base era quella di
medico l'ato sia a
Vienna era un medico ma anche
compositore quindi uno dei primi esempi
di medico musicista scrisse molta
musica Sette dei suoi balletti furono
rappresentati alla Scala di Milano e
scrisse alcuni trattati per l'epoca
importanti tra cui questo trattato
dell'influenza della musica sul corpo
umano e del suo uso in certe malattie
con alcuni
cenni Come si abbia ad intendere una
buona musica
lichtental non inventa niente traduce in
italiano le conoscenze che da secoli si
erano accumulate e che mettevano in
relazione la musica con stati d'animo e
il benessere addirittura qui lui
affronta le relazioni note e anche
proposte da altri trattatisti tra le
tonalità do maggiore re maggiore Sol
Minore fa maggiore e i vari stati
d'animo nel quadro a sinistra un quadro
molto famoso di Jan Vermer del
1662 vedete si intitola La lezione di
musica vedete una fanciulla di spalle
che suona un virginale il virginale era
uno strumento portatile che veniva usato
soprattutto per l'educazione musicale
soprattutto delle Giovani fanciulle
tanto che il termine virginale
probabilmente deriva da Virgo
fanciulla E vicino c'è un signore che
probabilmente il suo maestro ma il
centro del quadro se Guardate la
prospettiva non è la ragazza che è di
spalle ma il coperchio del virginale su
quel coperchio si intravede una scritta
perché era tradizione di quei secoli
scrivere nel La parte interna del
coperchio degli strumenti a tastiera dei
Motti sulla musica qui è scritto in
latino musica compagna di gioia medicina
dei
dolori avevano capito che esisteva una
relazione ma già dall'età dei Greci tra
la musica e il nostro
benessere questa eredità è rimasta
finché nel
2019 finalmente l'organizzazione
Mondiale della sanità ha pubblicato
questo importante
documento che
evidenza le relazioni positive
tra le arti la salute e il benessere in
pratica
l'oms raccoglie 4000 studi negli ultimi
20 anni che hanno evidenziato questo
hanno evidenziato che le arti e quindi
anche la musica fanno bene Non solo a
chi sta bene ma anche a chi sta male e
non aggiungono dovrebbero essere
inserite nei percorsi formativi del
personale
sanitario a questo punto
Beethoven ci dà un altro messaggio sulla
relazione tra le arti la musica e la
malattia immaginate di trovarvi nel
17 96 di avere 26 anni di essere un
pianista importante e compositore e di
iniziare ad avere un disturbo del udito
prima da un orecchio poi da un altro E
che in 15 anni vi porta alla totale
sordità
siete un musicista che cosa
fareste noi sappiamo cosa ha fatto
bethoven ha continuato a comporre grandi
capolavori ma in realtà bethoven stesso
ci dice cosa ha scelto di fare questo
importante documento è una lettera ai
fratelli nota come testamento dei
heiligenstadt K bethoven scrive col
desiderio che venisse Letta dopo la sua
morte come messaggio all'umanità dove
descrive il suo dramma esistenziale
causato da questa incipiente avanzante
sordità
tanto che lo aveva allontanato dalla
vita di pianista e l'aveva rinchiuso a
casa concentrandola nella composizione
ma non è stato facile dice Ho rischiato
il suicidio Ma come ha superato questo
Beethoven dice ho scelto di destinare la
mia vita all'arte non avrei potuto
lasciare questa terra senza dedicarmi a
comporre grandi opere è un messaggio
importante che ci dice varie cose avere
obiettivi a lungo termine ma betoven
nella sua musica ci testimonia una
musica che non è pessimista stranamente
le sue sinfonie finiscono sempre in modo
quasi Trionfale fino alla nona sinfonia
che porta valori universali di
fratellanza e riconciliazione per unire
le coscienze ma dice un'altra cosa che
anche di fronte a ostacoli
apparentemente insopportabili e
insormontabili dobbiamo guardare avanti
dobbiamo avere obiettivi e superarli
raggiungerli a questo punto mi chiedono
sempre ma questa musica e questa
medicina fanno bene l'una
all'altra È ovvio che io ho sempre
considerato le due cose interconnesse
avere la vita più dimensione Anzi più
vite la musica non è qualcosa con cui si
vive ma qualcosa in cui si vive Uno vive
nella musica non con la musica se io
stimbro il cartellino perché ho finito
il turno Non è che smetto di essere
medico e quando vado a
lavorare La musica è qualcosa che mi
porto sempre dentro la musica ha due
poli tra cui si muove l'istinto e la
ragione la ragione Era con la mano
destra perché Guardate un direttore
d'orchestra che dirige la mano destra
dal tempo e la mano della ragione la
mano sinistra che descrive il carattere
della musica la mano del cuore e che
cosa può fare la musica per la medicina
tante cose A parte quello che dice
l'oms per esempio l'astrazione non
innamorarsi della diagnosi Io studio una
partitura vedo una melodia poi
continuando a studiare scopro che c'è
un'altra melodia io ho visto un paziente
penso che è una diagnosi invece ne ha
un'altra oppure non ha niente quindi ma
innamorarsi della prima diagnosi mi dà
la possibilità di essere libero col mio
pensiero di non rendere il mio lavoro
meccanico di arrivare a una sintesi mi
fa pensare alla dimensione umana delle
persone ci dimentichiamo della
Dimensione umana di Beethoven che lui ci
testimonia con la sua lettera pensiamo
solo al fatto che è stato un compositore
migliora la comunicazione una regola
della musica ascoltarsi Se i membri di
un'orchestra non si ascoltassero non
potrebbero andare insieme e ci protegge
dalla inquinamento acustico siamo
inondati di rumore la musica permette di
organizzare suoni e silenzi e la
medicina fa bene alla musica sicuramente
il metodo scientifico ci aiuta a capire
meglio la musica sia la storia Le fonti
con metodo scientifico che è una
partitura che ha le sue regole i suoi
principi come organizzare risolvere i
problemi proio con un'orchestra devo
capire chi è sto nato chi non va tempo
perché quel passo non riesce ma cede
ancora
dell'altro che non è sempre
positivo Considerate che la medicina non
è soltanto il libro con le regole e le
linee guida la diagnosi la terapia la
storia delle malattie La medicina è
anche una professione che si realizza in
un sistema il sistema sanitario fatte di
regole di una organizzazione che viene
decisa dallo Stato e della politica i
medici Cosa fanno in base al progresso
scientifico elaborano linee guida Ma che
cosa è successo in questi ultimi
decenni progressivamente il
managerialism ha invaso la professione
medica gli ospedali si sono trasformati
in aziende E quindi è entrata la logica
dei Teti di spesa dei budget Cioè è
avanzato un potere amministrativo
soverchiante rispetto alla Mission del
personale sanitario che è sempre stata
legata a valori etici e non a valori
legati al profitto al costo o al
guadagno voglio darvi alcuni dati per
parlare ancora di
eredità dovete sapere che negli ultimi
10 anni Il sistema sanitario nazionale
italiano ha subito un finanziamento che
raggiunge quasi i 40 miliardi se
facciamo un rapporto tra la spesa
sanitaria il prodotto interno lordo
otteniamo un numero che quest'anno è di
6,7 leggermente Superiore rispetto a
prima del
covid Ci aspettiamo Ci Aspetteremo che
dopo la pandemia questo numero fosse
molto più alto ma soprattutto questo
rapporto ci dà la possibilità di
confrontarci con gli altri paesi europei
Dove In Francia e Germania e superiore a
10 negli ultimi 10 anni c'è stato un
taglio dei posti letto di 880.000 unità
con una media ogni 1000 abitanti di 3,5
posti letto rispetto a una media europea
di
5 dal 2004 vige un taglio sul personale
sanitario per le assunzioni che ha
portato progressivamente Senza
considerare il progressivo pensionamento
che ha un picco in questi anni di 15.000
medici specialisti carenti in ospedale
Cosa significa che chi è presente lavora
anche per gli assenti Cosa significa
significa che sono stati accumulati ben
5 milioni di giorni di ferie arretrati
non goduti che ogni anno il personale
della dirigenza medica e sanitaria
regala 12 milioni di ore non pagate che
questo personale è sottoposto anche uno
stress perché il 50% ha subito almeno
un'aggressione fisica o
verbale con stipendi che sono 40 50%
inferiori a quelli europei Cosa
significa tutto questo c'è un clima di
pressione un clima di pressione da cui
vediamo che il sistema sanitario è retto
dall'abnegazione dalla dalla dedizione e
dalla professionalità dei medici e del
personale della dirigenza sanitaria
dall'altro canto Il sistema è arrivato a
un limite non più sostenibile in cui il
personale sanitario è ostaggio del
ospedali che cosa Porta questo crisi
della vocazione dimissioni 10 medici al
giorno se ne vanno dal sistema sanit
Nazionale fanno altro vanno nel privato
vanno
all'estero se guardate i posti delle
scuole di specializzazione di medicina
d'urgenza il 75% è vacante non perché
mancano medici Ma perché i giovani
medici non vogliono più lavorare del
Pronto
Soccorso Il passo successivo è lo
sviluppo del Burnout la sindrome del
Burnout è una malattia causata da
esaurimento emotivo e
depersonalizzazione non ce la faccio più
questo clima di pressione mi porta a
vedere i pazienti come dei numeri a
sviluppare ansia e depressione perdita
di interesse e di motivazione dovete
pensare che questo problema non è così
trascurabile perché il 20% dei medici in
Italia è in Burnout se qui foste tutti i
medici vuol dire che uno su cinque è in
Burnout 1 2 3 4 Burnout 1 2 3 4 Burnout
e il Pronto Soccorso immaginate di
essere tutti medici di pronto soccorso
La percentuale Raddoppia vuol dire che
uno su tre 1 du Burnout 1 du Burnout e
come ce ne accorgiamo ce ne accorgiamo
soprattutto se facciamo un'attività
artistica perché ti accorgi che la tua
libertà di pensiero è limitata la tua
fantasia si impoverisce non è più veloce
come una vol
la tua motivazione Cala l'attività
artistica è un indicatore di queste
situazioni se non la fai
subdolamente tutto questo può
trascinarti
e che cosè che può fare la musica in
aiuto Beh Ce lo dice lo AMS ti dà un
giubotto an proiettile Ma questo non
basta però c'è una cosa che dicono gli
studi internazionali
fortunatamente con la
Anza e la passione per obiettivi a lungo
termine puoi prevenire il Burnout è
quello che ha fatto Beethoven e che ha
scritto in quella
lettera Quando ero ragazzo studiavo
l'organo in chiesa perché Frequentavo un
corso di organo in conservatorio e
quindi di notte quando la chiesa era
chiusa Andava a suonare a un certo punto
una sera Arriva un signore che io non
avevo mai visto si avvicina mi ascolta e
dice una cosa
Ricordati di non rinunciare mai alle tue
passioni Ricordati di non rinunciare mai
alle tue passioni e se ne va e io vorrei
lasciarvi questo messaggio e
ringraziarvi per avermi ascoltato
Grazie